5 55
on your wednesday morning getting real
about that real id you know we had a
story recently about renewing your
driver's license online so a guy named
larry sent me an email hey
can you get that star on your license
online too or do you have to go in
to show proof of identity of course he's
talking about the real id that i hope
you've heard about i checked with kevin
malone from the dmv he says
yes you do have to upgrade to a real id
in person and he says
there's a website for that
getrealnevada.com and that website
explains
back in 2005 congress passed the real id
act to set standards for the issuance of
sources of identification such as
driver's licenses
americans going to need a real id
compliant driver's license or another
accepted form of id
to get through airport security or enter
secure federal buildings
and just to make sure you're up to date
the deadline for getting that real id
was recently extended now
to may 3rd of 2023 larry thanks for
writing in thanks for the clarification
to kevin malone a link to the get real
nevada website
on our website eightnewsnow.com you
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully and please put
on that phone if there is something
driving you crazy email me traffic 8
8 news now dot com